hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my ant-man in the wasp post-credits
scene video we got so much stuff to talk
about Kevin Feige confirmed some big
details a couple weeks ago so I'll try
to explain what he said and how that
fits into the context of what we know
what's going on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
so obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the movie yet and there is
a new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so at the end of
the movie we find that Hank and Janet
have shrunk the quantum tunnel so that
it's small enough to fit into Louis's
van just to make a little less
conspicuous and easier to move around
hey can hope are still fugitives because
they refused to sign the sokovia course
they didn't really resolve that plotline
because they escaped from the FBI so
they're still trying to keep it on the
DL and Janet was presumed dead by shield
30 years ago so she'd have to answer all
kinds of questions if she just suddenly
popped up so she wants to stay off the
radar too so as of the end of the movie
Scott is the only one that's free and
clear so his three days are up he's no
longer on house arrest
he's totally free to go back and join
cap and the rest of the Avengers post
snap sure but what they're doing with
the quantum tunnel is is making good on
the promise to finish healing ghost of
her quantum state instability so they're
sending Scott down to the quantum realms
to collect quantum energy in a small
container really important detail here
Janet warrants him to watch out for a
time vortex because time moves
differently if she implies that if he
does get sucked into one they could wind
up exiting in the past or in the future
he'd accidentally time-travel and they
wouldn't be able to find him so remember
that idea time vortex very important
when he's down in the quantum realm
collecting that quantum energy there's
this explosion of color that looks like
the rainbow of the Infinity stone colors
so you like wait a minute this kind of
reminds me of the Infinity Gauntlet but
when he radios for them to bring him
back you find out that the snap shirt
just happened Hank
Hope and Janet have all been turned to
dust and Scott thinks that he's stuck in
the quantum realm they just slammed a
black like oh how's he gonna get
out so here's where we get to the Kevin
Feige Avengers for of it all Kevin Feige
confirmed this movie is mostly connected
to Avengers 4 even though the snap sure
is an infinity war moment so yes it does
connect to both Avengers films but the
bigger things are all the teasers that
they dropped
during the quantum realm scenes in
foreshadowing plot twist during Avengers
4 so a lot of the concepts that they
introduced during the quantum realm will
be important to how they fixed the
universe in Avengers 4 now the really
important scene in the service of this
is the way they explain ghosts
affliction in the way that Janet sort of
explains how the quantum energy has
changed her she says that ever since
ghost was hit with the blast of quantum
energy
she's been existing in multiple
realities simultaneously without being
able to control it so her cells are
ripped apart and put back together over
and over again the time vortex is
another way of traveling through time
without the time stone so remember we
lost dr. strange
even though Wong is probably very
powerful I don't know how big of a
character he's gonna be during Avengers
4 we've seen a lot of set pictures
implying time-travel so just remember
that in the back of your mind we've
heard about Cassie laying in the future
also remember that the quantum energy in
Scotts container can be used to
manufacture devices that will allow all
of the Avengers to travel between
different realities why would that be
important I wonder well if you needed
Infinity stones to form another gauntlet
and you couldn't steal them from Thanos
that's one way to get it but also Kevin
Feige said that we will be seeing
alternate versions of pre-existing
characters the way to do that is to
travel into different realities so there
are a couple ways that the Avengers
could fix the universe just based on the
evidence that we've seen in ant-man in
the wasp not even talking about the
rumors that we've heard so far yes that
they could travel back in time into
other realities to grab Infinity stones
and then use that to form a second
gauntlet and they just undo what the
annos had done but the other way too
would also be to merge aspects of
different realities with our own even
though that's the less heroic option
because it's kind of robbing Peter to
pay Paul like if he wanted to bring
spider-man back and you just stole a
Peter from another reality you'd be
stealing him from his Aunt May so that'd
be kind of a shady thing to do so you
know theorycrafting here Scott exits the
quantum realm accidentally in a time
vortex when he comes out there's a bit
of a time jump which explains why Iron
Man's hair is a little bit wider like
look at Robert Downey jr. 'he's hair
during infinity war then look at his
hair while he's walking around here he
looks like he's aged quite a bit maybe
like five six years so that also
explains the casting call for the older
version of Cassie Lange because during
the movie there were a couple scenes
with her where she talks about wanting
to be a hero like they practice in that
little tunnel at the beginning of the
movie like she's play-acting being a
superhero then at the end of the movie
when hope is talking to her she says I
want to be a hero like my dad I want to
help people so it's just all
foreshadowing her becoming stature like
she did in the comics when she gets
older so imagine that the time vortexes
of the quantum realm or the alternative
way of time traveling without the
Infinity Gauntlet because the way they
use the time stone makes it seem like
it's not powerful enough to take
everybody physically back in time it
even though we did see him turn back
time at the end of the Doctor Strange
movie to fix damage across a relatively
big part of the city it seems like in
combination with traveling into
different realities it just becomes much
more useful to go into the quantum realm
because if you needed to get things from
other realities you couldn't do that
with the time stone you can only take
stuff from our reality in if you wanted
to go back in time say like go back to
the original Avengers movie and steal
the tesseract and the mine stone then
that would actually break dr. Strange's
plan remember he said this is the only
way so things have to play out a certain
way and our reality but who's to say
that they can't go and steal things from
other realities as long as it's just not
people and as long as they put things
back at the end of the movie so if they
do wind up taking Infinity stones from
other realities that I imagine that
instead of doing the Illuminati thing
where they all become guardians of
different Infinity stones they just put
them back where they stole them from or
give them to their counterparts and say
just make sure that nobody gets their
hands on these ever like deep-six this
as much as possible because I don't
think that they would have had that
explosion of color like they wouldn't
have made the quantum realm resemble
some of the aspects of the Infinity
stones if they didn't want you to think
that that was a possibility like oh wow
this energy seems like it has something
to do with the Infinity Gauntlet so
we've all seen the little devices on
everyone's wrist in those
behind-the-scenes pictures now it sounds
like they might be using a combination
of the barfing technology that Ironman
during Civil War to look at their
memories and also use the quantum energy
that's got collected to infuse those
little risk devices and those are the
things that are allowing them to exist
in other realities or travel between
universes there's still a whole lot of
questions like who's gonna create these
like imagine Shuri gets her hands on
this quantum energy because she and
Ironman have relatively similar ideas
like they're both meant to be the
smartest people on the plan but they
think in slightly different ways and
Sheree has been thinking more about
what's going on with artificial
intelligence because she was
manipulating the mind gem trying to save
vision so you have to imagine that
they'll probably be a lot of Science
Bros scenes with Ironman and Sheree
trying to figure out what to do with
this quantum energy but remember Scott
doesn't have any real connection to
Wakanda he met Black Panther briefly but
he's mostly connected to Ironman like
the writers of Civil War even said that
if they hadn't gotten the spider-man
character then Ironman when he said that
he had a guy and went to Queens would
have ended up going to recruit ant-man
himself so he would have been team Iron
Man if Spiderman hadn't shown up so
imagine that ant-man exits in the future
then goes to try and find Tony Stark and
then explains what's going on with the
quantum energy where he came from and
the Avengers sort of catch him up on
what happened with Thanos and why
everybody suddenly turned to dust
because I think what happens is is no
matter what point in time Scott exits
the quantum realm he exits out of the
quantum tunnel and because everything
was rigged up in secret on this rooftop
here it's pretty easy to say it won't be
disturbed any time soon so he could exit
out he probably seen nothing so it would
seem like they've disappeared so he
probably thinks that they're still alive
but something just happened to them the
casting call for the older version of
Cassie Lange also backdoor confirms she
survived the snap sure in Scott exits in
the future he probably runs into her
where have you been for the last couple
of years dad we thought that you died
you disappeared like basically the same
thing that happened to Janet Van Dyne
happened to Scott and even though it's
not very important we should mention the
second post-credits scene is really just
the aunt that they had rigged up to
pretend to be Scott playing the drums so
we just meant to be a funny moment that
was the one that played after the entire
credits had finished but let me know in
the comments what did you think about
the really big post
credits scene and post all your Avengers
for theories in the comments below
remember quantum energy traveling
between multiple realities time vortexes
so time traveling without the need of
the time stone so right now the
timetable for big reveals for Avengers 4
is is that we're getting the Captain
Marvel teaser in a couple months they'll
reveal the official Avengers 4 title
after that I'm not expecting a whole lot
of footage for that but I do think that
before the end of the year we will see
some Avengers 4 footage so what will
happen over the next couple of days is
I'll do more ant-man in the wasp videos
just sort of explaining what's going on
do my full review Easter Egg video all
that stuff leave your requests in the
comments below click here to learn all
about the Eternals and the Celestials
during phase 4 and click here for more
Avengers for a title thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]